John is with us in Phoenix Arizona
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show John hey
thanks for the welcome Dave how are you
today better than I deserve what's up
hey I have a really well-paying job and
there I'm thinking about retiring early
however though they're offering some
additional money for me to stay and I'm
really I don't like it that work I don't
like being away from my family
job requires a lot of travel but it's
been very lucrative and I'm just curious
about your take on whether or not I
should take the extra money and stick it
out for a few more years or go about my
business a different way what do you
make 300 right now they're offering 400
to stay Wow what do you do I'm an
executive at a mechanical contracting
firm Wow to be a family business we sold
it a few years ago yeah you're killing
it man congratulations
well you're right that's breathtaking
money so it causes you to take a breath
and stop and look at it right so what's
your a financial situation you are you
debt-free and multi-millionaire yeah
we've been here for about seven years
never called to do a debt-free stream
but uh you know so we started your
journey in 2012 we've been debt-free now
for the last four years not started with
about $700,000 in debt and right now the
second our networks according to
personal you know this I won't do any
advertisement for anybody else
right now the net worth is four point
three nine seven okay and you're how old
I am 37 sir Wow okay so if you're
retired what are you gonna do with your
life well I think I want to take my me
you thought it just takes six months off
to go maybe RV around the country with
the wife and come up with a better
answer to that question because I don't
have one today okay alright because I
probably forty five years of our vieng
is going to get old so six months so six
months is pretty cool right and that's
fine and you've worked your butt off
your fingers to the bone you've been
gone from your family you paid a price
to win you've won and so you're gonna
you know you're gonna live like no one
else
for a little while that's great I would
I'm guessing at the point before I get
your advice for sure I think that if I
think if I take the six months off that
if I come back to work I can probably
get another job but it'll probably be
not like 180 to 200 range
I don't think understand I get this job
again no but you'd stay in town yeah you
wouldn't be traveling all the time away
from your family yes work normal hours
yeah okay so I had a minimum you could
do that
the second minimum would be to start
your own shop right I won't be able to
do that for two years - yeah it's okay
ironclad all right so that that's fine
you know if you did nothing for two
years the thing is I just don't want to
have a plan to do nothing for a decade
or two because that's not a good use of
a human as smart as you you ought to do
something you know because you're just
gonna you know your brains are gonna rot
so you know you need to use them and but
but six months off or two years off or
six months off and then if you you
couldn't start a thing non-compete but
you could work at a competitor I
couldn't work at a competitor in the
mechanical trade but I could get a job
doing like plumbing or electrical or
something else those service-related I
could but some of my skills are
transferable but I couldn't go do my
specific trade I got you okay well yeah
I mean so probably sounds like you're
gonna come back make 180 200 for a
couple years and then do something else
that is the dream whatever it is but but
the point is you're not gonna earn zero
income for the next decade right right
maybe the next six months but yeah
decades is a long time yeah and if
you're not telling me that I would quit
I agree with you okay you've done it man
I mean you're 37 years old you have a
five million dollar net worth you're
100% debt free you have the ability to
come home from a six month trip and land
180 thousand dollar job and after that
you probably could make even more doing
your own thing and that's probably your
future so it looks really bright I would
quit thank you for the clarity yeah you
yeah I assumed you've got enough liquid
assets to live off up for six
right yeah liquid money you can get two
or three million liquid yeah 20 million
look it's not in retirement that is not
in retirement my retirement is actually
pretty small over all the IRAs and 401ks
is only a couple hundred dollars okay so
you can live off the you know some
portion of the revenue created by the
3.8 during the six months and you're not
going to starve yeah I'm gone I'm done
you paid a price to win and the price is
too high and it's not that you're never
gonna make that money again or that
you're never going to make any money
again it's just we're not gonna you know
keep the candle burning so hot you're 37
you did it congratulations man
incredible very studly